a longtime friend of this program i love
being on his show late night with seth
meyers and seth is going to host
closer look thursday this thursday
october 8th at 8 30 p.m
8 30 p.m eastern on nbc airing
live eastern time from his late night
studio and rockefeller
center seth meyers here on the rich
eisen show how you doing seth
i'm doing well and you know i do think
you should let the peacock viewers know
that it's exclusive because they're
watching you right now and they want to
know
some other suckers aren't watching it
anywhere else you know you gotta be
where they are
you know that's a nice broadcasting
trick to make people who are watching
feel more special
exactly there's a look there's a velvet
rope outside
that's or they are tall enough to ride
this ride
absolutely it's a better way to think
that's well i mean you know i guess
we're measuring them by their
subscription of peacock is essentially
what i'm saying
how are you doing how's life for you
seth you're back in studio
it's great to see you there it's great
to see you doing your thing yeah it's
been about a month back in the studio it
was definitely a weird transition back
but you know the last seven eight months
have been all about weird transitions
and it's obviously a very different
place we don't have an audience we have
limited crew
but it does feel right to be back in the
building
uh especially with all the safety
protocols that they've put in place for
us here
okay and these are things that i notice
as a follicly challenged man and i
didn't expect to start this but i just
saw a photograph of you there and i've
been noticing all the videos and stuff
that i'm watching
have you not gotten your hair cut in a
while seth i've got a light trim but we
did go back to long hair
over the course of the pandemic and uh
it you know i think when you reach a
certain age
i'm on the other side of 45 and uh
you know i think that it takes a lot for
you to do a makeover ultimately
uh in my case it did require a worldwide
pandemic to decide that i could switch
my look up
to that or divorce and i said i'm
happily buried god bless you
this is what i ended up with fantastic
how much sports have you been able to
to to watch in the uh in the in your
personal bubble with your
father baseball didn't take off for me
but the nba bubble did
and certainly football is the uh you
know that the exact same intake although
you know until the big 10 starts up i
really haven't watched a snap of uh
college football but i've
been happy with the nfl and i haven't
you know as much as i would obviously be
happier if they were
fans in the stands i find myself exactly
as invested as i would be
without them there no i mean i i get
lost in a two and i know
uh that the sound that's being pumped in
um is
canned you know like it's it's made up i
think last night during sunday night
football
which was great they they did one series
without the the canned noise just
hearing
what's in the stadium and i found that
fascinating but the steelers are your
team so you are
you must be quite excited with the way
that
look last year in the end was more
exciting than it had any right to be and
that the steelers were ultimately
alive going into the last week of the
season but
it was a real slog a season to watch
without uh roethlisberger
so you know when you start a season oh
and three and then you you come back the
next year and you're three and oh i
i'm i'm perfectly happy uh delighted
with how things are going so far well i
mean
for the fact that we had an unscheduled
by a week well i know that yeah i know
um but
it's they seem to be you know buttoned
up defensively in the manner to which
you've grown accustomed as a steelers
fan
so far over the years yeah that's the
great thing about steelers fans it's not
uh we don't just want you to win we want
you to win the way we're accustomed to
right so you know there were a few years
where the steelers you know were scoring
a lot of points and given up a lot of
points and
and even if you were a playoff people in
pittsburgh it's like you know this isn't
this is my first choice on how i'd like
them to win so right now it's been it's
been really nice to watch yeah i
remember
the reason why i said that is because i
remember a few years ago
when the steelers were putting up like
40 points a game and ben was throwing
for 500 yards that steelers fans are
enjoying the wins but they quite didn't
know how to handle not
pounding the football and playing
defense and winning tight ones 20 to 17.
you know what i'm saying yeah you know
they're uh
there's like a joke a friend of mine
said you know how many um
uh people in pittsburgh would take the
screw in a light bulb uh
one discrete i think it's five like one
to screw it in and four to talk about
the steelers in the 70s
it's some version of that i've told it
badly
you know when you're that successful uh
for a decade people like it that way and
it does it is the style that
that matches up with the psyche of the
city and i think it's very rare for that
to happen but
you know when it matches up right it's a
nice fit and i guess well
this what i try to do as a broadcaster
seth is tie things together and what we
talked about
hair your hair uh and then now the
steelers
uh i'm wondering if you caught the
photograph of ben during the pandemic
and that might have scared you because
he looked full
uh we've got the photograph up here full
duck dynasty beard going on
and it was kind of hiding up what could
have been
a a not ready for playing physique
um and i'm wondering if that might have
been concerning at the time and we have
seen obviously
ben uh be uh ready to roll since then
yeah there was a fullness not just to
the beard but a gin
like a general fullness i would describe
the
the the winter ben look uh but you know
i think
uh when uh you know when a 38 year old
guy who's obviously
uh seems very happy with his family life
when he makes a decision to come back he
has to know that you know the body has
to be in a certain place or else it's
not worth it and
uh so but it's been it's been really uh
nice to see
seth meyers here on the rich eisen show
hey seth i get a lot of
stick to sports whenever i you know
stick my uh
my thumb up uh to test the the political
winds and might tweet something or
like something i wonder what your
philosophy has been
uh in these times if you get stick to
comedy stuff or
or what your two cents has been as we're
getting again ready to see your uh
closer look thursday thursday night
um well i would say when i was a uh both
in middle school and high school when i
played sports most of my
coaches said stick to comedy
okay i've never i've certainly never
heard stick to sports at no point
yes i get that quite a bit true this is
a very true story which is my
i tried out for football okay and the
football coach of my high school
was the dad of a friend of mine so i
knew him
as a as a friend's dad first and
no one who tried out for football in my
high school got cut
you just made the team i was the only
person in the four years in high school
got cut and what he did was he brought
me in and he said
look i'll keep you on the team but i
just feel like you have better things to
do with your time
come on this is a true story and he cut
me
and i was so mad at him because it was
so embarrassing
it was noted not just by me i was noted
by many that i was the only person to be
cut in my four years in high school
and then he became the guidance
counselor at my high school okay
and i got on snl and i went back to
speak at my high school
and i walked in the hallway and i'd been
mad at him for over a decade
and i saw him in the hallway and he
pointed me goes what did i tell you
it was this incredible moment because i
realized oh
i've been mad at this guy who was so
right
i mean the only other way is that i come
back as an nfl player and i pointed him
that's right
he gave you proper guidance certainly
i've never heard story but you know
it i will say look i think that uh all
late night shows or certainly a lot of
them
uh yeah i think the audiences have a
sense of what's authentic from each host
and and what they're gonna get
you know none of us are sort of running
our opinions
through any sort of machine it's not
like the network's coming to us and
saying we'd really like if you thought
this instead of you thought that
so while i appreciate that there's
certain people who would only be
frustrated to watch a show like ours
you know we're trying to make sure that
if you're watching me i'm telling you
things i believe and we try to back it
up
and hopefully uh people can appreciate
that that if they don't agree with us
at least we're not um telling you things
that aren't fact-based right and again
that's
late night with seth meyers airing
weeknights 12 30 p.m
um 12 30 at 12 35 a.m on
on nbc so what what do
what should we expect on closer look uh
thursday it's coming up right after the
i guess it's right after the vp debate
so that'll be happening yeah
i mean i rich look if you didn't ask me
on uh yesterday morning what would we
what can we expect tomorrow i would have
been wrong
it is insane you're right it you know so
it you know one of the things i keep
saying is
it has that there's been a weird if you
look for silver linings in bad
situations
i do feel as though i've gotten my
weekend back in a way that i don't
really have to pay attention to i mean
this weekend was obviously an exception
because
of the magnitude of it but more often
than not what's new
saturday is not worth having on tv on
monday because it's so far in the rear
view
so you have to it's a little bit you
know i did come from a background as
being an improviser and part of being an
improviser is you
live in the moment because it's not
about planning ahead of time it's about
being in a position to react quickly
but you know the reality is we're doing
a live show on thursday and we'll see
you know obviously we'll go into it
thinking it'll be about the vp debate
but it's
i find it hard to believe that something
won't happen over the course of thursday
that we'll bump that
of course you never know what do you
think of uh jim carrey's
joe biden what'd you think about that
that was really good you know i think it
is a trick a tricky impression i
you know uh in my era i thought sedakis
did an incredible job
um but uh you know for somebody to line
up with uh
alec baldwin i think jim carrey
obviously is that same sort of pedigree
and it was really fun to watch okay walk
me through
a couple of minutes we have left here uh
seth meyers joining me here on the rich
island show walk me through what happens
in the halls of snl and the writing room
when a debate like the one that we saw
between trump and biden happens
what what wha what happens is it does a
siren go off or
an actual literal you know there is a
siren going off ahead of time and i will
say that when i was there
you know in the last round of debates
presidential debates i worked on the
show was
uh you know 12. okay uh everybody sits
around
you sort of group write uh the debates
in that
anybody can sort of send in a joke or
whatnot because of the structure of a
debate sketches it's a lot of q a
so anyone can have a small thread of an
idea that if you're the person
in charge of sort of putting it all
together try to keep your ears open
because that tends to get the most out
of a situation like that
i mean this was a tough one because it
did look like
there had been a debate we all missed
and we were watching the snl version of
this
right so uh i did not you know i
i texted uh josten shay you know even
before
this weekend's news happened that again
skewed what the perspective on
everything was but
i you know i oftentimes long for my days
at snl and something happens and i think
oh
i wish i worked there i did not feel
that after watching that that is
funny and sad all wrapped in one one
sound bite right there
seth i'll be i'll be honest with you you
know because again so
because right i imagine though some of
the things that you're you're doing on
your show
although it is not meant as satire it is
meant as comedy it's
it's not far off you know from uh
from everything that's going on in the
crazy ass world obviously you're having
more commentary of serious nature but
i mean yeah it's still you know we
always you know
as people will say you know do you
really think you're changing anyone's
mind and if there's any mind we hope
to change it's people who are on the
fence about whether or not they're going
to vote
right i think i'd like to hopefully make
you realize
there is you know a pretty large
uh weight to the idea of voting now
i also hope we provide some catharsis to
people because again i don't think we
should be anyone's first news source but
i think if you watch the news all day
it might not be the last you know the
wrong thing to do to watch a comedy take
on it um
right before going to bed uh if if we
can do that like because again when
you're on at 12 35
so all you're trying to provide people
is a good night's sleep right
yeah you're speaking to somebody who did
a 2 a.m sports center for seven years so
you know i totally know it you know look
i caught a few of those i kind of
which i'm i'm pleased about hey seth i
look forward to uh coming on your show
uh in november um and you've always been
you know kind having me on but also you
come back
you know i don't people know this but
you go back and you chit-chat quickly
with the guest and
you know you make everybody feel so
comfortable and so at home
um so do do you go in the virtual
waiting room and do that
um and and also uh do i get a mug
sent to me as opposed to because i'm not
gonna be there seth how is this going to
work we will get a mug in the
mail to you there will be a mug
dispensation for anybody uh
but this is a peacock thing that's not a
rich well i've already got a peacock mug
right here
um because you know there may be an iron
rich in eisen i'm
still a team player okay i just want to
make sure that and
and again i just want to make sure that
everyone is aware
um that i'm going to be on and that it's
just going to be i'm virtual i'm not
physically going to be there
virtual it is uh i will say it's the you
know we're managing uh to be as
efficient as possible
in these times like it is strange to not
have uh the chance to sort of say hello
backstage particularly with people we've
been on before
and and i've been lucky enough to get to
know over the time so i do a little post
interview chat on the zoom
uh rich so you will uh we'll be able to
catch up then fantastic i look forward
to it thanks for the call i look forward
to thursday night uh with closer look
thursday on
nbc at 8 30 p.m eastern time and of
course every single night
uh with you thanks for the call seth all
right all the best rachel be well
that's seth myers closer look thursday
again on
nbc at 8 30 p.m eastern uh it's going to
air live
from his late night studio in
rockefeller center and then again
seth meyers late night with seth meyers
you can catch on peacock
before it hits network television that's
how you roll
with this subscription oh
every night at nine eastern time and as
you can see on the screen right there
you can watch um this season and last
season
sitting right there in the archives hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here